[موسيقى
] لورد كان ينوي القوس
لإعادة إنشاء لعبة Titanic Embrace الشهيرة التي
ألعبها ولكن في هذه الحالة ما
حلّق هو خواتم الخطبة التي
سحبها سكوت كلاين من جيبه في صندوق
شاهده وهو يرتد من على سطح السفينة
[موسيقى]
اندفع بعد ذلك إلى خليج ساراسوتا على
ساحل الخليج بفلوريدا ، ثق بي
أثق بك ليس بالحلقة التي
تمكن سكوت من إخراجها من المشروب
لأن الصندوق كان بطيئًا في الغرق ،
لم تستطع سوزي تاكر التوقف عن الضحك ، صعد سكوت
مرة أخرى على متن القارب ونزل  على
ركبتيه وانتهى مما كان قد بدأ به وهو
مبلل ، قالت نعم ، ثم
وضع خاتمًا عليه وقبلوا المشجعين
صرخوا لرؤية الخاتم الذي كتبته العروس ،
لا أطيق الانتظار حتى أتزوج
صديقي المفضل AKA.  الرجل من
حوله ربما لم يشعر بالسلاسة في
أعقاب ذلك مباشرة
يا صديقي كيف يمكن أن يكون الخطأ قد ذهب أوه إذا حدث خطأ بالفعل ، كان سينتهي الأمر بالحلقة
حيث فعل تيتانيك
[موسيقى]
جينيموس سي إن إن نيويورك